hi my name is amber guillens and i am
gore district's next ambassador
i grew up in a slightly larger little
old town called rotodua and yes you do
get used to the smell
eventually
my mum and dad still live there and i
have a younger brother who now lives
across the ditch in melbourne for
christmas i send the card but not the
present
do you know how much posters cost these
days
after graduating winston heights high
school i moved to palmerston north to
study at messi university
graduating last year with a ba in
linguistics and psychology
you wouldn't believe how handy it is in
so many ways
i moved to gore in the same year and now
have a fantastic role at invercargill
city council as the health and safety
coordinator
from bluff to the museum to the water
treatment plant and my job every day is
different
and that's what i love about it people
ask me why don't you move to
invercargill why do you choose to live
so far away
honestly
because i love goa
and i love the people of goa every
weekend there's something going on from
hakanoi fashion awards to the saint
peters faire even the local lads showing
off their lady wares and every time the
people back it a hundred percent and
they back each other 100
they have been so friendly
open and accepting of me and i want to
pay it back
as the next ambassador i would have the
chance to sell gore on its people
because it's the people that sold it for
me
i hope this is helpful and about why i'm
here so thanks to you and thanks to the
gore toastmasters for their support
cheers